This episode is brought to you by Ridge wallet.
What's up wisecrack Michael here.
Welcome to the first episode of our new series book versus film,
where we'll size up the differences between our favorite films and shows and the
novels mangoes in comics they're adapted from,
I guess it should be called film slash television show versus novel slash comics
slash other source material. But well,
whatever and rest assured this ain't no listicle and classic wisecrack fashion.
We'll ask the eternal question. What does it all mean? Our first case study,
Chuck politics, 1996, novel fight club and its transformation into the 1999.
David Fincher film of the same name on the surface.
The movie seems like a near carbon copy of the book with a few minor details
changed.
But what if those minor details actually changed the message of the film let's
find out and obviously spoilers ahead for the book and novel.
Oh.
For starters, let's see what the film and novel have in common.
The basic story beats are pretty much the same in both.
We open on a guy with a gun in his mouth before jumping back to the events that
brought him there, uh,
faking it at a cancer support group with another phony named Marla meeting,
a guy named Tyler Durden who convinces them to start a fight club,
that fight club escalating into a terrorist faction called project man.
And the big surprise reveal. Tyler is the narrator's alter ego.
We end back at the beginning, the narrator with the gun in his mouth,
killing off Tyler Durden. So basically the same story, right?
Even some of the most memorable speeches in the film are taking practically word
for word from the novel.
When you buy furniture, tell yourself that's it.
That's the last sofa going to need? Whatever else happens. Got that.
So problem handling.
Don't call the film a carbon copy just yet. Let's take a look at the minor,
but meaningful differences between the two. Now, before we compare and contrast,
I want to give a shout out to someone who helps us keep the studio lights on
this week's sponsor. The Ridge wallet.
The holidays are coming up and a wallet gift is so underrated.
Most people are probably still walking around with their old lumpy leather
wallets from the eighties, but the Ridge wallet is an awesome upgrade.
It's light, sleek, industrial,
and it doesn't fold awkwardly in your pocket with such a minimalist design.
You might think you're sacrificing room for everything you carry,
but the Ridge can hold up to 12 cards and still has room for cash.
They're made of durable materials and come with RFID blocking technology to stop
digital pickpockets. The best part is that they come with a lifetime warranty.
So this may be the last wallet ever by the rich team is so confident that you
will love it, that you can try it out for 45 days and get a full refund.
Don't check out all their styles and options by going to rich.com/wisecrack.
If you use code wisecrack at checkout, you'll get 10% off.
Now back to the show difference. Number one, this line,
as it turns out a lot of the criticisms of the movie justified or not can be
understood through this line.
Uh, Tyson has, is chasing cars and clothes working jobs we hate so we can buy.
We don't need.
Now before you fight club stance, throw your books at me and protest. Yes.
This line is taken from a very similar one in the novel, but strangely enough,
in the book it said by one of Tyler's henchman the mechanic.
So what impact does this difference? Make well,
director David Fincher spelled it out in an interview,
explaining that the real act of sedition would be to spend a ton of money on a
film and to put movie stars in it and get people to go and talk about the
anti-consumer his rantings of a schizophrenia madman.
Having Brad Pitt a bonafide.
A-listers give these anti-consumer his speeches legitimizes the arguments and
it worked. People still emulate Tyler to this day.
If you search Tyler Durden jacket on Amazon, well, you can take your pick.
That's not the only difference to make sure people invested in Tyler and his
message, the film softened, many of his rougher edges, for instance,
and then novel Tyler eventually becomes homicidal killing the narrator's bus and
the mayor's special Envoy on recycling. Let's uh,
go to the book and see about this one. Marla yells,
you shot the mayor special Envoy on recycling. Tyler shot the mayor,
special Envoy on whatever. However,
the film goes out of its way to show that Tyler has no intention of harming
anyone not killing anyone, man was setting them free.
So there's the whole blowing up the credit card buildings thing.
But movie Tyler makes a point that the buildings are empty.
And even when he threatens a convenience store clerk at gunpoint,
it's revealed the gun has no bullets getting rid of Tyler's darker
characteristics makes his ideology all the more enticing.
It's easy to dismiss the words of a homicidal madman,
but it's much harder to do so if that person technically isn't hurting anyone.
So clearly Tyler Durden takes on vastly different meanings as a character when
you compare the film to the novel,
but that's not all difference to the meeting.
The way the narrator first meets Tyler is also dramatically different in the
film here.
The narrator first encountered Tyler on an airplane during a business trip,
but in the novel he meets his other half while he's lounging on a new Veatch.
Why this change? See,
there are two facets to the narrator and Tyler's relationship,
the mentor mentee aspect, and the more carnal side,
the books meet cute is pretty homoerotic. The films, airplanes, you know,
ever primarily presents Tyler as a mentor,
introducing the narrator to unsettling new ideas.
You know why they put oxygen mask foam planes so they can breathe.
Oxygen gets you high in a catastrophic emergency.
You're taking giant panic breaths. Suddenly you become euphoric docile.
You accepted.
This speech mirrors, the narrator's status quo.
He's a corporate drone moving through life without any agency,
just like the people on the plane he's accepted his fate.
He will work his dead-end nine to five job in perpetuity. Tyler, however,
jolts the narrator out of this comfort zone.
How's it working out for you? What being clever. This is the central tenant.
To their dynamic in the film and mentorship where Tyler forces the narrator to
examine his life choices and break free from his self-imposed shackles. However,
in the novel, when the narrator first meets Tyler he's buck naked in the sand,
and what's the very first thing the narrator notices about Tyler, his body,
how I met Tyler was I went to a nude beach.
Tyler was naked and sweating gritty with sand,
his hair wet and stringy hanging in his face.
Just one second now, to be fair,
the film definitely plays into their homoeroticism with bath breaks,
petty jealousies, and all,
but it also blurs the line between the narrator's jealousy of Tyler's
hyper-masculinity and his straight-up sexual desire for the guy in
contrast the novel by having the meet at the beach,
really centers the plot on the whole. I want to be,
and maybe want to bang this man thing,
but it's not just the central relationship with the story that changed,
which brings us to Marla difference. Number three,
Marla's backstory the film explicitly frames Marla as an unfulfilled
object of the narrator's desire.
And also is this kind of mirror image just as he fakes having diseases to get a
good cry. So does Marla and this infuriates him.
You liar, you big tourist. I need this.
But this paired down version of Marla necessarily excise as much of her
backstory.
And this in turn makes her a far less sympathetic character than she is in the
novel.
And the film Marla doesn't really have a reason to go to the cancer support.
When asked about it, she simply says.
It's cheaper than I'm moving this free coffee.
But in the novel Marla tells the narrator that she goes to these groups to feel
more alive. Let's go to the book to check this one out.
All her life Marlin never saw a dead person.
There was no real sense of life because she had nothing to contrast it with.
Now that she knows where we're all going. Marlin feels every moment of her life.
Later on in the film, Marla asked the narrator to check her breast for lumps.
I need you to check and see if there's a lump at night.
The narrator checks doesn't feel any lumps and then immediately asked to leave.
However, in the novel, the narrator actually does feel a lump. And what's more,
this isn't the first time it's happened to Marla turns out her first breast
cancer scare is what prompted her to go to the support groups in the first
place. So yes, the narrator's description of Marla is identical. And the film.
Marla's philosophy of life was that she might die at any moment.
The tragedy she said was that she didn't.
But it takes on an entirely different context in each version in the film,
the line comes across as a little edge. Laurie,
even ironic since Marla isn't sick. However,
in the book it's a tragic declaration.
Marla might actually be dying and she goes to a clinic to see,
but leaves after deciding. She'd rather not know if she is dying.
She doesn't want her life to end in a drawn out process of being stuck in a
hospital. But her tragedy is that she won't die.
Unexpectedly saving her from the prolonged ritual of dying from cancer or
anything else as a result, everything Marla does,
including her suicide attempt has extra weight in the novel, but in the film,
Marla becomes merely a goal for the narrator and it means to expose his own
self-loathing. He believes that if he can become more of a man,
he will be deserving for affection. This isn't a mutual reciprocated love store.
It's all one side within a masculine man puffing up his own ego so that he can
be macho enough to ask a girl out.
So basically Marla gets a short shaft,
different number for the credit card building,
but we haven't dealt with arguably the most action packed part of the story,
the whole terrorist term. Now in the film, Tyler plans to blow up buildings,
housing, credit card companies in the novel, he has a very different target.
Why is this interesting? Because it further changes how we view him.
And the film Tyler's plan is to destroy any records housed by credit card
companies, giving everyone a clean slate.
Out these windows. We will view the collapse of financial,
this one step closer to economic equilibrium.
However,
in the novel he's far more self-motivated viewing himself as a messianic figure.
His ultimate plan isn't to destroy a bunch of credit card companies.
Instead he wants to blow up the tallest skyscraper,
which will topple onto a national museum,
taking himself out in the explosion as a murder,
his ultimate goal to prop himself up as a legend and become immortal. Well,
let's check this part out in the book. This isn't really death.
We will be legend. We won't grow old.
Whereas Tyler's plan in the novel is presented as purely self-aggrandizing
destruction. The film as a selfless political angle,
something that audiences would in fact, even root for.
This was very much intentional as producer Ross, Grayson bell recalled. I said,
what if they blow up the credit card companies and everybody woke up one day and
they didn't have to pay their bills.
We needed something where the audience members would cheer the destruction of
the world.
The film ends with bombs exploding as Marla and the narrator watch holding
hands. Even if we know on some level that Tyler dying is justice served.
We can't help, but sympathize with him and his cause at least a little bit.
However, in the novel, the bombs never go off.
Tyler's plans are thwarted by his own incompetence.
And this kind of makes them the punchline, not the hero, nothing explodes.
I say, Tyler,
you mixed the nitro with parafin didn't you parafin never works
here.
Tyler's failure serves as a reputation of everything he's espoused and stood for
this change effects.
How the audience ultimately views the character in the novel.
We laugh at Tyler yet in the film, we cheer him the difference. Number five,
the last ending. Okay?
So the movie ends of buildings collapsing in a pixie soundtrack,
but after Tyler's failure, the book keeps going. And this is really important.
After the bomb malfunctions,
there's an added code where the narrator wakes up and what he believes is
heaven, but is actually a psych ward.
So why does film end on an uplifting note?
Whereas the novel ends with him arguing with a psychologist.
He mistakenly believes is God it's because they're not going for the same theme.
The film focuses on a man discovering his confidence and reasserting his
manhood. Whereas the book stresses a man rebelling against his father,
both in the paternal and religious sense.
This is why the film ends on a triumphant note.
Since the narrator owns his masculinity and triumphs over Tyler,
he wins Marla's affections. However,
the book's ending reflects a far more ambiguous message. According to writer,
Chuck Palahniuk.
The central message of fight club was always about the empowerment of the
individual through small escalating challenges in a way it's like everyone
rebelling against dad and discovering their own power by killing the father.
As the Buddhist would say,
eventually you have to kill your father and kill your teacher.
The film touches upon this, kill your father theme in a moment,
adapted from the novel as the narrator and Tyler discuss who they wish they
could fight. Most Tyler reveals.
He wants to beat up the father who abandoned him.
I'm a dad. I don't know my dad. I mean, I know him,
but he left when I was like six years old, married,
this other woman had other kids.
Both the novel and the film then extend this absentee father figure into a
metaphor for God himself, just as fathers abandoned their unwanted children.
God has abandoned this world.
This sentiment is expressed in nearly identical lines, said by Tyler,
in the film and the mechanic in the book.
Those were models for God. If our fathers bailed, what does that tell you about?
God, listen to me.
I have to consider the possibility that God does not like you never wanted you
in all probability. He hates you. This is not the worst thing that can happen.
However, the novel takes this one step further than the film.
When Tyler is first introduced on the beach,
he uses logs of wood to build a makeshift hand in the sand.
Also that for one moment, he can sit within the hand of his creation,
Tyler shrugged and showed me how the five standing logs were wider at the base.
What Tyler had created was the shadow of a giant hand.
The giant shadow hand was perfect for one minute. And for one perfect minute,
Tyler had sat in the Palm of, for perfection. He'd created himself.
In this instance, Tyler has forsaken God and become his own creator.
This moment for shadows, the creation of fight club and project man,
and which Tyler and the narrator become gods or fathers to their followers,
to everybody there I am. Tyler Durden,
the great and powerful God and father.
And just as the narrator's father abandoned him.
He too ultimately does the same thing to his own children,
turning against the space monkeys and trying to tackle their terrorist regime.
But it's not quite that simple in the novels Coda it's revealed that many of the
orderlies in the psych ward are actually members of project, man,
waiting for Tyler to return. Cause every once in awhile,
somebody brings me my lunch tray in my meds and he has a black guy or his
forehead is swollen with stitches. And he says, we miss you, Mr. Durden,
the end of politics novel. Unlike the film,
isn't a perfect triumph or the narrator. He's still stuck in his own delusions,
surrounded by his unwanted children.
And ironically he's become the very thing he was rebelling against in the first
place an absentee father. But what do you think wisecrack space monkeys.
Do you have a preferred version of fight club?
What other differences did you spot in?
The two versions sound off in the comment and let us know what you think.
Also let us know what you think of this new format and what other books and
movies you'd like us to break down, hit that subscribe button.
Like it's your hotter alter ego's nose and be sure to ring that bell huge,
thanks to our patrons for all your support and as always. Thanks for watching.
Later.
[inaudible].